hey guys to be Ryan I'm going to be
going to the premiere of 300 rise of an
empire Legendary Pictures a real a
badass company who did like the Batman
movies I came out recently Superman they
invited me because they saw my awesome
trailer reaction because I'm that cool
they were like you know what you should
come to this premiere and I said sure
why not and I love walking around
Hollywood because everyone just keeps
looking at me recording myself see look
all these people have to wait and for
people well I get a Glin ah you got big
stars here like William Shatner brutally
I'm sure all you got to know that is and
of course coach Utah that's Godzilla in
Spanish in case you guys don't know and
for all your YouTube haters I know it's
not Spanish I mean it's really cool like
Godzilla has a star but why does he have
a starter exactly oh my god guys it's
james earl jones i'm about to go to will
call I've never been in premier before I
have anxiety right now oh my god oh my
god look what it says look what it says
it says I'm going a little call I'm
going will cough this is really exciting
I like the first 300 Gerard Butler
Gerard Butler talks like the right side
of his face you guys ever noticed that
like agua agua Clark I look good in the
shadows gosh I have a big nose ooh
we're gonna have people look at that how
awesome is this now I don't really know
anyone who's in this movie but I'm
assuming they're all like really ripped
and cut because if this is 300 after all
like see this guy over here I don't know
him but he's really good-looking this
guy one day that's like guys going to be
me one day that's right it's gonna be me
I'm not gonna be here as you guys can
see they have a black carpet not a red
carpet it's the el capitan over there
that's where Jimmy Kimmel is he sleeps
there they're really exciting you always
see stuff like this on TV but you never
actually get a be there for it and I get
to be here for this so this must mean
I'm pretty important I must be more
important than a lot of people out there
if I'm actually here I'm gonna be so
famous looks really expensive to put a
premiere together this is TV stations
this is where things get broadcasted see
this is cool because these guys are
recording in the stars and stuff you
know it's going to be on TV but I get a
record the people who are recording the
stars which is way cooler in its own way
I know a lot of the people who subscribe
to our channel are not familiar with
this but this is the mann's chinese
theater they used to only allow Chinese
people in there but now they allow all
kinds of races in there it's pretty
amazing they actually have a IMAX camera
now and you all know how much I love
imax so out of here it's one of the
largest screens in the planet these are
the handprints and footprints of a bunch
of celebrities being Crosby I've
definitely heard that name Jack Benny
these are true legends because
everyone's heard of them before I'm
trying to get this shot perfect doing
whatever I can by creating you this is
can't see it because i'm a horrible
cinematographer but this is michael
caine's footprint and enfert and his
writing and I love Michael Caine
he was in the movie can't Carter the
remake with Sylvester Stallone that's
the one that he's really famous for
really exciting stuff this is michael
caine he has the tiniest hands I've ever
seen you would think Michael Caine had
bigger hands and that they just told me
to get my idea ryan right lady I'm
getting my ticket right now I'm getting
my ticket she laughed at my joke I like
this woman it's my old photo idea right
here you guys see that I have to show
you the actual ticket I have to show you
they're taking not just the envelope
okay is the real deal people see that
I'm gonna be like this guy one day oh
yeah I think he shaves his armpits and I
am so excited to watch a bunch of bluff
men make me feel really fat right now
we're about to go in the theater people
I'm really excited I just got told that
I gotta head in so here goes time to get
some popcorn and feel bloated while I
watch these guys look really good oh
look at that rise of an empire so I hear
you might get something for free where's
the soda and popcorn for the soda
popcorn spree that's what happened yes
they're excited too that's what's
happening this is my drink that's gonna
go in my belly
this is all the free popcorn that
everyone's going to get including myself
as I'm special it's gonna be in imax
today people it's gonna be in 3d and
apparently I don't know how to wear my
imax 3d glasses so I'm not sure if I'm
allowed to recording so I'm trying to be
as quiet as possible look what's above
me this used to be a place of worship
and this used to be the God that they
would pray to look how gigantic this
screen is I know a lot of people have
said they don't know what I max is well
when these curtains open its going to be
the most humongous screen you've ever
seen and I'm not sitting in the middle
but I'm sitting to the far right and
nothing is better than experience in
movie from the far right okay so i just
got to have a movie oh my god that was
an experience I max is the way to go for
this film for sure I just heard there's
an after party right now this is some of
the coolest news ever I think I might go
to the after-party
eva green a stupid girl yeah maybe I'll
show up ok guys so apparently i'm headed
her to an after party right now and oh
my god i think it's the start of the
movie over there i get to go to this
after-party well a lot of people who
actually went to come here don't get a
job ah can't talk anymore there's a
little preview for you guys of
awesomeness here goes
alright guys so I just got out of the
after party met a lot of big tymers I
remember any of their names but they
were big they're pretty important people
uh yeah the movie just saw it it was is
pretty incredible actually I was really
impressed by it I saw the first one the
other day just to you know get my mind
refreshed and I really liked it but I
thought I kind of locked in some story
and this one I thought they totally
improved on the story a lot you know
they gave you a lot more
characterization even had a better
dynamic between good versus evil like
eva green in it was awesome hey she's
pretty sexy for a villain she's just a
freaky character okay she's scary you
just think she's gonna chop someone up
at any time there's this sex scene that
everyone's talking about it's like if
300 had a sex scene just imagine it like
that and it's it's pretty insane it's
not like that little thing that you saw
with Gerard Butler and his wife in the
first one it's like a full-on sex scene
and it's pretty awesome and I max I'm
just gonna say that yeah Eva Green like
at one point she just cuts off a guy's
head and then kisses the decapitated
head he's a pretty freaky character she
said she's damn good villain she's a
definite you know scene stealer and the
guy who played uh the second gerard
butler Kiki's name is like Thea mitis
for Thea meatus something like that
fetus he's the male lead I don't think
he's as you know compelling or as
gripping as Gerard Butler but they
weren't trying to duplicate Gerard
Butler they were talking they were going
for a different character whereas the
Spartans are more like just badasses who
are unbeatable except the course of the
end of 300 these guys Athenians are just
more human they're just men most of the
time they're just as cut as the Spartans
but you could tell there more they're
not as skilled as family and it's it was
cool because it was also like a it's
like a prequel mainly but semi sequel at
the same time is a little confusing at
first but when you adjust to it it's
cool how they tie it all in like oh
that's what was going on with the
Athenians when Spartan people were doing
their thing at that time look the main
thing you go for for this movie is not
the story and stuff the main thing
you're going for is the action the
facials all that stuff and they totally
over deliver on it the cinematography of
it was just absolutely excellent there
are so many shots that I can recall that
we're just badass they were just bloody
brilliant they don't give away all the
cool shots in the trailer like there are
some really cool shots the director
wasn't trying to copy Zack Snyder's
direction he did his own thing with it
I'm crossing the street so if I die for
you guys that's why and it's extremely
bloody okay you thought the first one
had violence
oh this one is like 10 times more
violent look people are just getting
chopped up left and right like body
limbs are just flying everywhere people
are getting hacked up way more than in
the first one it's just non-stop blood
for like the majority of the film it
makes it ten times cooler and I saw this
in imax 3d um yeah you gotta go only way
to really experience this film is imax
3d imax is just absolutely incredible
and the 3d was actually really good and
you don't get that with a lot of movies
these days but in this one you're like
wow I really feel like there's blood
splattering all over me another thing
too that I thought was really cool the
music was awesome too like the music was
really good it got my heart moving and
everything it especially added to the
finale the finale was so good when the
movie ended I had so much chills I guess
one thing that I thought I kind of
lacked in a little bit was focused on
xerxes because everyone was saying this
is based on the comic books or a tease
but Circe's is kind of focused on in
like the first 10 minutes and then like
you kind of forget he exists for most of
the movie it's just a weird guy over all
know they like they put more focus on
Eva greens character which I much rather
preferred my hair looks funny didn't
realize how funny look till now because
I was sweating up a storm in the theater
because that's how awesome this film was
gotta watch on imax that's like the best
way to go i saw the first one in imax
and this was a better imax experience
than the last one so definitely check it
out
thank you guys for watching